do you think like this is i mean we know
quarterbacks are going to continue to
play
right up up into the late 30s early 40s
all of that but
like are these two going to be you know
a once in every 30 or 40 year type of
thing or do you think this will be the
common trend do you think like
seven well you know seven years from now
eight years from now ten years from now
we're going to be talking about
you know it'll be more than that sorry
like patrick mahomes versus josh allen
and they're both 42
years old do you think it's going to go
that way with all these young stud
quarterbacks like what's your feel there
well my feel is that it will for a
variety of reasons and let me say this
first because
when matt hasselbeck retired he was just
about
40 and may have been 40 and right
it caused me to research at the time
quarterbacks who had performed at a high
level beyond the age of 40.
and the list was basically brett favre
he turned 40
during the 2009 season with the vikings
where
but for his crossbody throw in the nfc
championship game that was intercepted
by tracy porter causing our friend paul
allen to yell
this is not detroit this is the super
bowl but for that
he would have gone to the super bowl at
the age of 40. there aren't many
quarterbacks beyond him
who have played past their 40th birthday
at a high level in the nfl
i think it changes now for one very big
reason two
number one guys know how to take care of
themselves now and they put a lot more
into it than they ever did before
around the calendar focused on
staying healthy and young and vibrant
and active and
and able to compete with guys half their
age number two
the rules are conducive to without a
doubt don't touch the quarterback rules
help keep guys healthier deeper into
their into their lives and allow them to
play longer it's that simple
yeah no you're right that that's really
it is that simple but i'm with you i
just was curious you know did you think
this would be like oh we'll never see
this again
but i i i agree it's just the way
players are staying in shape
you know staying after themselves brady
of course has brought great awareness to
everybody too which i think is going to
you know help these guys
as far as what they do to attack it um
but i would think it's going to be a
consistent thing it's just amazing how
quickly it moved you know that's where
i'm that's where i'm amazed
my dad in 1993 was 38 years old
and i the whole year you know i was i
was 13 years old so i remember the whole
year everybody was amazed with how good
he was playing at 38
and he was the oldest quarterback ever
to win a playoff game
at 38 which is crazy and then you're
right favre changed it and now i feel
like we're going to see 40s on a
consistent basis as we go forward
peyton manning was 39 when he finally
called it quits
and he felt older than 39 because he had
been through more physically and it was
kind of rickety and it was a
a limp to the finish line for peyton
manning in the 2015 season
but there's no way he could have
squeezed another year out of that
week week one of that season yeah week
one
somebody that i know was in the bowels
of the
stadium in denver and saw peyton manning
outside the locker room doing all sorts
of funky stuff just to get loose to play
week one right it's like man this guy's
a mess
and so yeah with brady
he's the trailblazer and i i don't think
he's going to stop at 45 chris
you know he he has said the year that he
turns 45 he turns 45 early august
that would be 2022 right
that's his last year according to
everything that he said about how long
he wants to play
i'm not ready to say he's going to be
done i'm i'm not
not based upon how he's playing right
now because he's managed to defy father
time father time remains undefeated yeah
but it could be that tom brady holds him
off even longer than tom brady thought
he could hold him off but
i mean i will i won't be shocked well
but i you know we're definitely gonna
get next year
right that's for sure but but as we know
and again brady's defying a lot of this
it
when it does fall it's it's gonna fall
in a hurry
where i feel like it'll be one of those
things where we'll be like man brady
just got old like right in front of our
eyes like what the hell happened
but as it looks right now i mean i'm
with you mike
i mean i i swear you know he i think he
runs
faster now than he did in 2011 and and
his throwing is every bit as powerful
and accurate as it's ever been so as
long as he's willing to take the beating
and feels like he can move just enough
to get out of harm's way
i mean yeah he's definitely going to
finish next year there's no doubt about
that
45 and beyond it's it's certainly a good
question right now
i remember thinking very early in his
career
that he must have done a damn yankee
style deal with the devil
to be as good as he was 2001 2 3 and 4
after he was this frumpy looking dude
that came out of michigan as the 199th
pick in the draft
so i mean if he did a deal with the
devil he's getting the best of the
bargain
he's letting him play all the way into
his mid 40s so i think my deal with the
devil
theory is actually gaining momentum the
longer this guy plays
it's it's unreal i i mean
again i'm one that i'll sit there and
tell you i don't think brady's
you know the greatest quarterback ever
but
as far as consistent greatness longevity
i i don't know that's not even a
conversation anymore that's that's like
that's out the window as far as just
year after year of great years
you know that's where it's like we get
into the the conversation about
you know the the gail sayers versus
let's say
the frank gore's of the world with the
hall of fame you know with the
quarterback situation
okay i don't think brady and his prime
is as good as some of the other great
quarterbacks of all time elway
you know aaron rodgers of course them
but how was rogers the second name well
i'm just throwing names out
either way but but but what i'm saying
is you
i guess you i have to start balancing
how good he is for how long he is too
and take that into account which which
means something and it's really
special what brady's doing there's no
doubt about that throw in the six super
bowl wins and quite possibly a seventh
at some point although it's not going to
be easy for tom brady and company they
got to get there first and then when
they get there
it's not like they're going to be
playing a team that isn't equipped
to win the super bowl but you mentioned
aaron rodgers
he's the next one to play past 40. he
said he wants to play past 40. and then
he got russell wilson who's 32 who has
said he's gonna play until he's 45
recent events tell me that all of those
seasons may not be with the seattle
seahawks maybe sooner rather than later
sorry to get seahawks fans riled up
early on a thursday morning but
it's 408 like local time not many of
them are listening right now they'll
listen to the rear they'll get upset
when they watch nbcsn
in in a few hours but
i think this is where it's going and you
throw on the third factor we talked
about
diet nutrition exercise that allows
guys to play longer rules that are
conducive to it
third we're talking about an obscene
amount of money
relative to what other guys make well
franchise quarterbacks make an obscene
amount of money and that rubber band is
going to continue to be stretched
that is the ultimate incentive to keep
playing it gets back to your dad's
advice to brett favre
don't stop until they rip the uniform
off if you know why would you when
they're stuffing your pockets
with cash to keep playing no you're
right about that yeah
i'm gonna keep playing yeah you're the
teams don't show good quarterbacks to
door anymore
you know that that used to go on now
it's it's really like oh we don't want
to upset the fan base and he's
you know it's been such a big part of
our organization and oh man he still
sells a lot of jerseys
so we're never going to really cut the
ties with them that's where it's changed
where
back in you know 80s 90s you didn't see
that
when teams felt like quarterbacks were
getting to the end it was like okay
sorry see you see move on move on time
to go we're gonna move that on
and now it it goes back again to the
quarterback is on the same pedestal
with what they're making for the most
part is the owner they've they've
trumped the coach as far as power in the
organization in a lot of places
and this is part of that conversation
and why it's all working out this way
oh it's a point that i make all the time
when we talk about how coaching pay
hasn't grown at the same rate as player
pay and salary cap
a good coach is worth more than a good
quarterback now a great quarterback is
worth more than a good coach but
you know we talked a couple of weeks ago
after jared goff broke his thumb and
he's making 33.5 million a year i'd
rather pay sean mcvay
three and a half million a year than
jared goff and you got bill belichick
who's making north of 20 million a year
there are quarterbacks out there who
aren't all that good who are making
north of 20 million a year yeah i'm not
going to name names derek carr but
and derek carr is better than i don't
want to go all in on derek carr this
morning that was gratuitous
and unnecessary and i apologize derek
carl but he's a guy who
and and i'll tell you what given where
the market's gone his 25 million per
year or thereabouts
isn't it's ridiculous now yeah it was a
little ridiculous at the time
to make him the highest paid player in
the history of football that was a
little ridiculous
right now it's in a good spot relative
to others but still
i'd rather have bill belichick than
derek carr wouldn't you no definitely i
mean yes
you'd really have i'd rather have bill
belichick almost over than anybody i
mean it doesn't even matter
you know it may be a handful of the
young stud quarterbacks right now but
the rest of them i'd go
i think i'll take belichick so yes he
he's special that way and we can't
you know forget we just talked about you
talked about peyton manning
first week limping into it again there's
just too many examples of teams going to
the super bowl winning the super bowl
with rookie quarterbacks rookie
contracts
guys getting to the final four in the
super bowl that are not that special
aka jared goff jimmy garoppolo hey
peyton manning was the worst quarterback
in football when he won the super bowl
i was like people got to remember that
so
uh i i as we have talked a lot i think
the world is going to turn here
i think there are more and more people
in the nfl
who have heard what we have said and not
that that they've never thought about it
before but
this is it this is going to be a thing
that's going to be talked about
in organizations as they go forward wait
do we really want to pay this guy
35 million dollars is he really that
special or can we find somebody else to
do the exact same thing
and yeah it might piss off our fan base
for like a few weeks but
we can get them for half the money and i
think that is going to happen here as we
go because there's just a lot of damn
good talented quarterbacks out there
right now
since we have gone completely off the
rails yeah and haven't even begun to
talk about what we were planning to talk
about
i think that is probably pulling his
beard out right now which may be a good
thing based upon what his beard looks
like
i digress but but here's
here's where here's where pizza what did
i do
here's where the rubber meets the road
on that analysis
and it doesn't just have to be a guy
who's early in his career
and a team says no we're not going to
give him that presumptive
big contract we're just going to find a
new quarterback in seattle
where they are going back to 2012
right and they are going to go run heavy
in two years
that's when mark rogers the agent for
russell wilson at the latest will be
banging on the dr
on the the door for the next market
level contract for russell wilson he's
currently at 35 million a year
that was top of the market at the time
the top of the market now is 45 million
who knows where it'll be in two years
but whatever it is
rogers is going to want that for russell
wilson and the seahawks are going to say
why we're not getting our money's worth
see at some point
at some point there's going to be
irreconcilable differences between the
seahawks and russell wilson about his
value and his role
because if you're going to have a
run-based offense you don't need to be
paying your quarterback 45 million a
year you're better off drafting a kid
from wisconsin in round three and hoping
it works out and i feel like at some
point
and it's both sides at some point i feel
like russell wants to see what he can do
somewhere else
and at some point the seahawks want to
see what they could do with someone else
and save a hell of a lot of money in the
process so that's one big
big area where this theory could could
blossom and a lot of people be like
what's going on
well if you've been paying attention to
the business realities you know what's
going on yeah well no i mean
your your points are real i mean i mean
i think they're borderline factual
really i mean
the fact that we know seattle was
reluctant to want to pay him that type
of contract anyways
we also know and we discussed last
off-season
they thought and flirted about moving on
you know i we brought up we had the
conversation there was a discussion with
the browns for the number one pick
russell wilson to the browns everything
i know
seahawks were going to take josh allen
that's what they wanted to do that was a
plan so their mind has been there
and you're right we'll see where it goes
i mean yeah do you need to pay a 30
a quarterback 35 million dollars a year
if it's all about the run and the
defense
probably not no but you know if it is
still about the offense and run the game
and then we want to be special play
action
and make special plays off that well
we'll see where that goes but yeah we
don't know
what this new formula is going to look
like in seattle with the new offensive
coordinator whoever that may be
my brain is now fully activated without
the benefit of caffeine
regarding all of the possible alternate
realities that would have occurred
if russell wilson had landed with the
browns would russell wilson be playing
patrick mahomes this weekend
josh allen if he was with the seahawks
would they be hosting a game this
weekend as a high seed in the nfc
fascinating stuff to ponder and it just
shows you that
that that relationship it it seems to
the outside
that it's a lifetime deal recent
developments underscore
the reality that at some point they are
going to reach
a decision that that quite possibly will
result in russell wilson playing
elsewhere and the seahawks
going much much cheaper at the
quarterback position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports